ball has just broken out over the Lake
District a helicopter has been shot down
and the situation is escalating
okay I'm gonna uh start the Convoy again
it's an exercise of course but one
that's being carried out in an entirely
virtual environment that promises to
change the way we train our military
allows us with one single synthetic
environment which can be streamed to you
know anywhere in the world so players
can be in different parts of the world
it replicates the real world physics it
replicates a real world terrain without
using real fuel or ammunition typhoon
pilots fly over the same virtual terrain
jackpot acknowledged being used by
ground troops drone and satellite
intelligence teams feed them with
information in real time using
simulators for military training is
nothing new but massive improvements in
cloud computing power artificial
intelligence and machine learning
software as well as Hardware like
augmented reality headset now make it
possible to bring large numbers of
people into a simulated environment of
the real world and allow them to train
together in real time
the computing power is large enough for
AI to represent 60 000 civilians in the
environment which alter their behavior
individually according to the battle
around them in this team all of them
need to see different things but they
need to see it in a common operating
picture keeping that up to date in real
time with 60 000 AI entities running
around and adapting to an emerging
situation is a complex computational
task so we are the plumbing that sits
underneath that
if it looks like a computer game well
that's because it is hadian has worked
with the developers of games like
Minecraft to help scale their Virtual
Worlds
but isn't real war very different it's
important that the Armed Forces keep up
with the expectations of the younger
generation where they're now very
versatile on this equipment My worry is
because of pressures on budgets that we
will see the flight simulators we will
see these digital classrooms take over
from getting out into the field and
doing real life experience because in a
world of hypersonic missiles and
autonomous drones that experience is
changing too For Better or Worse
computers already fight much of our
battles make sense to train with them
too
Tom Clark Sky News Lancashire